notre étape du jour nous emmène acciona
à 4550 km à l'est de moscou
le soleil n'est pas encore levé sur
cette petite ville de sibérie orientale
mais la gare est déjà plein à craquer de
gens qui attendent pour monter dans le
train un train très particulier entre un
hôpital qui sillonne les régions les
plus éloignées de sibérie pour offrir
aux habitants des soins de première
classe
dix wagons 25 spécialistes et parmi eux
beaucoup de passionnés comme valérie
antonoff qui travaillent à bord de ce
train hôpital depuis plus de trois ans
absolute mayotte lourdes président
j'adore les trains quand j'étais jeune
je rêvais d'être conducteurs de train
finalement je suis devenu médecin mais
je travaille dans un train bondé votions
valérie et médecins échographistes et
dans le train la queue est toujours
longue dans l'étroit corridor de vent
sur compartiments j'aime mon travail
parce qu'en tant que médecin j'ai
toujours voulu aider les gens surtout
dans les régions éloignées
matt dillon tollé la réalité est que ces
gens ne se rendront pas par humaine dans
un hôpital dans un grand centre
mais après qu'on les a examinées ils
vont être suivis est très têtu mais le
but premier du train hôpital et le
dépistage et le diagnostic échographie
rayons x mammographie analyses de sang
et d'uriné
tout est fait sur place et les résultats
sont disponibles immédiatement
le train permet surtout aux patients de
voir en une seule journée quantité de
spécialistes qui leur aurait été
autrement impossible de rencontrer un
cardiologue un neurologue ophtalmologues
et ce entièrement gratuitement mais
entre le premier j'ai déjà attendu deux
jours pour essayer de voir un chirurgien
et un endocrinologue ici en une seule
journée
j'ai déjà vu presque tous les médecins
et en outre la shoah ou et c'est très
bien ils font tous les tests échographie
électrocardiogramme
c'est très pratique pour les gens âgés
tout est financé par la compagnie de
chemins de fer russes rjd elle opère
ainsi cinq trains hôpitaux à travers le
pays dont le but était à l'origine
d'offrir des soins médicaux à son
personnel ses mines et sur le large
territoire de la fédération de russie a
tendance à gaza
c'est notre devoir le devoir de hergé
des vis-à-vis des employés du trend et
de la population en général
dans la plupart des cas le train est le
seul moyen de joindre ses populations
nous arrêtons dans beaucoup de petits
villages où il n'ya parfois que quelques
maisons mais il y a des gens qui
habitent là et qu'ils n'ont pas
l'occasion d'aller dans les grands
centres pour obtenir un diagnostic
alors on s'occupe d'eux
le toit ne reste jamais longtemps au
même endroit quelques jours tout au plus
c'est lorsqu'ils arrivent dans le petit
village de tarki ce que l'on comprend
vraiment l'ampleur des besoins
ce village
zinaida moudouwana l'habite depuis
toujours elle est enseignante à l'école
primaire ici et a vu targuer se vider
peu à peu de ses habitants depuis la
fermeture de la scierie le village est
isolé presque coupée du monde
les routes sont dans un état lamentable
on ne peut pas se rendre jusqu'aux
grands centres le trait est le seul
moyen de transport on est très éloigné
c'est presque impossible d'évacuer des
blessés ou des malades d'ici ils
risquent de mourir quand un trajet m'ont
jeté ce qu'un chat une ambulance à
quatre roues motrices seront chercher
les personnes âgées incapable de se
déplacer par elle-même un trajet
inconfortable jusqu'à la gare où les
attend le train hôpital zinaida elle s'y
rend à pied une marche d'une quarantaine
de minutes
comme les autres habitants de tabriz
zinaida temps des sucres à l'hôpital
depuis longtemps et pour cause il ne
vient qu'une fois par année
je suis venu passer des examens
j'ai vu cinq médecins j'ai fait tous les
tests du tout va bien
les personnels et très accueillant le
besoin est très réel
j'ai vraiment l'impression de faire mon
devoir de médecin quand j'aide ces gens
qui n'ont nulle part où aller
paul convenance
ce qui est aussi particulier pour les
médecins les infirmières ici c'est que
le train n'est pas seulement leur lieu
de travail
c'est aussi l'endroit où ils vivent tous
partaient 6 sur la route qu un jour à la
fois laissant derrière eux conjoints et
enfants pour vivre dans des conditions
assez spartiate totaux chirac quand on
le met le sacrifice que l'on fait dans
sa vie personnelle et familiale est
totalement compensée par la satisfaction
que l'on ressent on est dans ces gens au
web
ici je peux lire boire du thé le soir je
vais super puis je sors faire du sport
ou de le dire à tout ce que j'aime le
plus c'est que je peux aller pêcher et
ensuite on fait cuire les poissons ont
fait de la soupe ce qu'on ne peut pas
faire en ville
et pour valérie antonoff c'est aussi
l'occasion de voir du pays
sopo mines chimie s'est installée ces
géantes est plein de magnifiques
paysages de nature de montagne des
tunnels j'adore le monde des trains bien
sûr je prends plein de photos du
tournage nous verrons
et pour lui découvrir son pays à bord
d'un train c'est de loin le meilleur
moyen
la prochaine étape de notre voyage à
bord du transsibérien nous emmène voir
l'une des plus belles section du trajet
celle qui longe le fameux lac baïkal une
région où l'industrialisation a
longtemps été synonyme de pollution mais
où des changements se pointe à l'horizon
et je vous invite à consulter notre site
internet à l'adresse que vous voyez à
l'écran
vous y trouverez le carnet de voyage de
jean françois avec de magnifiques photos
des commentaires et des compléments
d'information